I am seen at work as a very assertive and aggressive dude and I seem to rub
people the wrong way when they think I'm upset or frustrated at problems they
the present,
which is rarely the case.
I'm just so fired up.
How do I work on Mike hacked while still being assertive with my team?
You know what?
I'm fired up too.
How you liked that Jagan and w when I was young I,
this is
when I was younger.
Sure.
I rubbed some people the wrong way.
I know that even when I was a young kid working on a construction site,
guess what?
I was doing work in too hard,
making people rubbing people the wrong way.
When I got to the team,
those little crew of us that were too hardcore,
we were too fired up.
We were,
I would run the o course with my,
with with a ruck sack with a 40 pound pack,
a 40 pound sandbag in it.
No one was doing that,
like everyone does it now.
But back then there was a small crew of us that were doing it,
running with jungle boots all the time instead of in sneakers.
And I literally got pulled aside by some of the old guys.
And by old guys,
I don't mean nom,
I mean old guys from wherever,
uh,
you know,
from the,
from the nineties or the late eighties.
And you know,
I'd get the,
hey,
you just need to calm down dude.
You know,
you need to do that.
And so yeah,
maybe I wrote those guys a little bit the wrong way.
Understandable.
But when I got a little older and a little bit more mature,
I got fired up to actually do a good job as a leader to actually build
relationships with my platoon mates.
And I got fired up
for people to,
instead of thinking that I was upset or frustrated what I was fired up because I
wanted people to think that I was calm and cool and collected.
So how's that for?
Don't totally different.
It's like when we say default aggressive and I always say,
hey,
you're not being aggressive and being aggressive towards your people.
It's not yelling.
It's being aggressive towards the mission.
I was,
I'm aggressive towards making people think that I'm not upset and that no matter
what's going on and they just look man chocolates,
he's not going to lose his temper.
He super levelheaded.
Right?
Um,
now that being shed,
that doesn't mean that I was passive.
Sure.
That doesn't mean that I wasn't assertive.
It means that I was aggressive and assertive,
but I did it with tact and instead of coming to people straight on,
I flanked them.
I've listened to their little ideas or I made their ideas come from me,
but they didn't know it.
I listen to their solutions.
I helped him supported,
well,
how do you go so far?
Just by helping people out and helping them with their idea instead of trying to
control them and make everything your idea.
So that's my advice here.
Relax,
calm down,
focus,
get fired up,
get aggressive about being tactful,
get aggressive about working with people,
get aggressive about showing your calmness.
That's what you get aggressive about.
Don't get assertive,
aggressive,
and create antagonistic relationships across your
company.
Check sounds good.
He said he,
he gets or they think he gets upset or frustrated at problems that they present,
which is rarely the case.
He said,
he said,
I'm just fired up.
So it's,
it's,
it seems like,
and I'm no expert,
but I'm trying to put myself in this position where like,
I think maybe like it,
it's just a presentation thing,
you know?
Like he definitely has a presentation is aggressive.
Like he's saying he's not even getting frustrated.
I'm getting frustrated with him for fracking this,
right?
Yeah.
It's definitely a presentation thing.
No doubt about it.
But,
so that means you say,
okay,
I'm presenting the wrong thing.
I will fix what I'm presenting it.
D Do you think,
actually I think you do think this or know this or whatever.
Oh,
you know how people,
they'll,
they'll get nuts or whatever.
They'll,
they'll,
they'll be aggressive.
They get fired up.
Right.
And you know,
the,
whether it be they'll lose their temper or their behave in a way that's,
that's aggressive towards people and their justification is not to say that this
guy does this.
I don't know.
But I'm just saying their justification is I'm just passionate about it.
I'm just whatever,
you know.
Um,
is that,
that's just the justification,
right?
It is because,
yeah.
Like if at the end of the day
it is,
it's a joke.
It's a justification.
It is also a reality.
So think about it from the other perspective.
If,
if you're dealing with someone,
if you have someone on your team that gets all that,
they're,
they're passionate about something and it can be problematic if they don't learn
to control their passions,
right?
Cause they just get,
Hey,
we're gonna make this happen.
And they make bad decisions because they're so passionate about making something
happen that there dot did not doing something logical.
So yes,
you could say it's just an excuse and there's no such thing as a passionate
person.
But that actually wouldn't be true.
It's not an excuse.
It's a real thing.
Now,
if you are aware of that,
then why do you keep acting that way?
You've got to put your passions into check.
That's what you gotta do.
Hundred percent.
Yeah.
And I meant more like it's an excuse for their behavior.
You know,
like,
to me,
I personally,
I think that being passionate about something that you're into is good.
Wayne beneficial,
of course.
But again,
you know how to say like there's a difference between what you feel and how you
behave,
you know?
So if you're,
if you're super passionate about something,
it doesn't justify it.
Like all this aid rational or emotional or like loss of temper situation,
behavior.
You see what I'm saying?
So,
you know,
yeah,
be passionate,
but don't behave in some crazy off the handle.
It
agree.
So I think that they use their passion as an excuse for their behavior.
I just got a quick temper man.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It doesn't mean that you can act like that's worse.
That's
exactly right.
Yeah.
That's just how I am.
I'm unique in that way.